the robert altman award recognizes
ensemble casts who
together achieve something truly
transcendent
and this year the filmmakers and actors
telling the story of cassius clay
sam cook jim brown and malcolm x reached
those heights and honored the men with a
story worthy
of each of their unique greatness
i feel like this is a love letter to
black men it's so honest it's so
wrong together yeah we are fighting
for our lives everybody
there are guys just malcolm it's jim
it's cassius before muhammad ali
it was about the celebrity and what are
we gonna do with that
it's an actor's piece and i'm an actor
four of the right actors could just
have a meal who's the greatest
we have to be there for each other why
because can't nobody else understand
what it's like being one of us except
us she never shows anything but energy
and ideas and creativity everything's
not so black and white like you make it
out to be
it's amazing to work with someone who
understands acting process
as much as she does you know you
bourgeois negroes you're too happy
uh with your scraps to really understand
what is at stake
here she understands how to help us
reach a choice
without forcing us to get to that place
i mean if the goal is for us to
really be free then you know it is then
the key
is economic freedom we want the world
but we're safe to be ourselves
all four of them are different men and
different actors the thing that they
have in common
is that they're all great
i'm so proud to recognize this year's
winners of the robert altman award
director regina king casting director
kimberly r hardin and ensemble cast
kingsley benadir
eli gorey aldous hodge
and leslie odom jr congratulations fam
on behalf of the entire cast and crew
of one night in miami uh we would just
like to say thank you
thank you for the robert altman award
i'm so grateful to the cast uh to leslie
who's been like a big brother to me
aldis who is such a consummate
professional
kingsley so driven and committed to
character
i learned so much from being around you
guys playing malcolm x in one night in
miami
was the most stimulating
and wonderful acting process i've had
so far i feel so lucky to be able to
share this with
the fantastic regina king and my cast
and kim
harden she did a fantastic job casting
and it's so great to be able to share
something with her
i'd like to thank the director regina
king
for the opportunity of working with her
after knowing her for so many years
and helping her see her vision through
on her directorial debut
thank you to our fearless
leader truly kent powers we wouldn't be
here if it was not for your script
brother
the dialogue was truly the star
we recognized that what kemp wanted to
do in this script was to have a private
conversation
publicly a conversation about um
[Music]
black life and and our humanity these
are conversations that i
witnessed first when i was a little boy
i grew up to have them myself in
anticipation of this movie being
released
in the year that it was we're like you
know what is our responsibility
to our people to this moment to our
country
regina king thank you so much um
you've changed my life with this role
with this movie regina
this i i can't say enough about your
leadership and your guidance your wisdom
thank you so much for your vision and
your confidence again thank you
independent spirit awards
cheers everybody